[Music]
so listen let me tell you Tom about
calling him a Handler B remember when
Joe Rogan uh [ __ ] said that Brandon
needs a Handler
let's see this is our buddy too lazy to
try the one who's at war with Tim Dylan
so in this video we have Brendan Schaub
discuss that voice yeah and look at that
Avatar I don't think he's a war with
anybody yeah that's a good point I don't
even care man it's like whatever it's 10
billion sucks but I'm just gonna tell
everybody sucks and move on it was
[ __ ] great okay so remember this yeah
he needed to he's wrong about the theory
he look Brennan's my boy but he needs a
Handler he needs someone like me around
him all the time what are you gonna do
no no no here's why yeah and he'll go
yeah you're right and then Brennan
responded to this and he obviously
wasn't too happy about it but he's
mostly just going after Dana White
supportive for your Bobby Lee is one of
my closest friends I mean Bobby talk a
lot no one's been more supportive when I
started than Bobby Lee dude and it seems
like he could never finish his sentence
I don't know if he just cuts himself off
because he knows that it just sounds
ridiculous or because he's Brendan and
he's just confused sometimes
by the way he's just confused sometimes
it's hilarious you need is a better team
around you have all the resources in the
world and I see kind of you know this
from time he's talking about Kanye okay
this is very important you have to hear
that he doesn't get it ready and he's
just confused sometimes you what you
need is a better team around you have
all the resources in the world and I see
Connie you know this from time to I see
about the people around you should be
ashamed of I see Kanye from time to time
I see him all the time
and then he says things anyway Brian's
looking at him
and watch this you know this from time
to I see him all the people around you
should be ashamed of themselves that
they allowed you I don't think he's
controllable I don't think I think the
minute you tell him what to do you get
fired
yeah Kanye's like that
that damn Kanye mm-hmm such a Kanye big
gay lion is walking on big gay eggshells
around you every [ __ ] day so don't
start with how [ __ ] being afraid of
being fired all right Papa
I don't that the problem with with power
like that is you surround yourself with
people who are looking for a paycheck
and they just know they're dealing with
crazy
come on man
seriously I think he's just telling
Brendan to his face yeah that's what it
feels like right and they just yes you
to death so they get the money but
that's probably Brian's definitely right
here I don't think anybody's really
getting through to Kanye I don't want to
get into all that drama too much but I
think it's going to take a lot for him
to change his mind and like they said
I'm sure he just surrounds himself with
yes men like most people do that become
insanely famous so then after this
Brennan starts talking about how Joe is
able to handle criticism and talk about
and if one of his friends disagrees with
what he has to say they can call him up
and he'll listen to them and maybe
change his opinion and I guess they all
just do that for each other and that's
how they get into talking about the beef
that Brendan had would show I guess Joe
called him up afterwards and talked to
him about it and Brendan now is claiming
that was all just a joke but I feel like
that's something Joe told lie
[ __ ] lying me first off I don't
believe that Joe called him how about we
start with that
because I'm gonna go even further saying
but even Rogan has more money than God
but if Rogan posts some or something
anything
you can call Rogan like what are you
doing I'm like God you're [ __ ] right
dude that was what I'm saying
no
you're lying
I've had times where like Rogan we'd all
do that for each other well how come
nobody called you and told you not to
[ __ ] go after Bobby Lee with the with
death threats in the police
I was like if I tell you you've done
that
why is Brian yelling we've done that
before I've done it he's crazy
I know why I can't answer for you it's
not his fault I'm going to defend him
you're dealing with sir interrupts a lot
you have to be louder he will interrupt
you you have to to you you've done to me
multiple times Rogan did to me like when
I was in this got so out of hand with
the the conspiracy with Dana and stuff
like that yeah caught me joking around
joking around they just got a hand like
you were trying to create it but then
when you put my
he was joking around you doubled down
and said that was definitely
a scam he was joking around guys
that's the talking point he was it was
only joking
then we put me against the wall I'm like
hold on hold on here dude yeah it did
not sound like Brandon was joking around
when he first talked about it but maybe
he's like a cry for help to try to get
Joe's attention or something everything
he's doing is a lie you're [ __ ] lying
if you guys are so cool how come you
weren't invited or sober October and
everybody else was
[Music]
but Brendan is right it was a good way
to just stir up some controversy and get
people talking about him and a lot of
people did actually believe in The
Conspiracy Theory but then I think once
people realize that Brennan believed in
it they stopped talking about it
Andrew Schultz sits I hate the way
Andrew Schultz lives yes that too 38
year old [ __ ] wigger talking [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] sick of him especially after
that Kanye thing he did that monolith by
the way monologue that he does Jesus
Christ just like he [ __ ] robbed the
TJ Maxx
priced almost somebody standing at a bus
stop outside of a TJ Maxx so [ __ ]
seriously what are you a [ __ ] kid on
his first day of [ __ ] School [ __ ]
school yeah seriously holy [ __ ] wait is
that like for a school for retards or
where they teach you how to be a [ __ ]
yes
and did that whole stand-up thing
oh it was renamed to the San San
Francisco comedy College
talking about Dana which was pretty
funny and talking about Dana the
Instagram post that he made going after
Dana obviously like people goofed on him
and Joe got pissed but it was pretty
funny and people are talking about it so
it's not that bad and it seemed like he
enjoyed it Andrew Schultz sits away did
[ __ ] Martin Short there when he did
Jiminy Glick when he was messing around
you know it sounded like something is
wrong with us what
Bobby Lee
[Laughter]
I hate you
what's his what was his wife's name in
June June I was speaking with June
earlier saying that Bobby Lee was
cheating and they broke up because of
you is that true he starts hitting it
with a paper
I would give anything to have a Jiminy
Glick interview or Brendan chop I would
[ __ ] do the best and by the way if
you've already watched all the chimney
clicks and you can just watch hey ew
because RCA City borrows bro he does I
think he's admitted it too you know he's
trying to get a more little pop his
shirt off yeah he's like now the chicks
are watching he's like yes and the audio
people are furious at you
under his skin but then also this Oh I
thought these were going to be glasses
of wine they're plastic that killed me
did lead to Joe needs a Handler which
Brendan was obviously not too happy
about because then as we'll see right
here Brennan talks about how he called
combat world show and he's like dude
that's not cool you shouldn't have said
that I don't believe all this but if I
were going yes I do that's right and
then Dana picks it up and I do stuff and
even Brogan's like what are you doing
dude why would I need to make a bit
about it I'm like I need con like for me
it's fun ah he almost slipped hear that
car slipped I need content did you hear
that yeah for me it's fun I need content
you got a lot of shows to fill up time
on it you ain't got Yovan I'd sit there
for two hours now and go hey man what's
with that outfit man you look like some
kind of some kind of gay astronaut or
something man what are you doing man you
look like some kind of bedazzled rodeo
clown or something dude what's literally
that's that's literally how Brendan made
money I don't know if Theo just rip up
my sneakers for now get out of here I
need a Content yeah and I was like you
know I still don't dislike Dana all
right funny goes don't do that all right
you're right
fashion thing now where everybody looks
dirty they're dirty like I mean
he looks like he should be standing at a
7-Eleven at 7 pm getting his dinner good
point off the bat fresh off the back of
a pickup truck Mexican Chic yeah he
looks like he should be standing in a
[ __ ] Home Depot parking lot I can't
wait for folks uh day worker uh show
they're gonna do lately it's going to be
people with lawn mowers and Mexican hats
honestly he's gonna she's gonna show up
with grass stains next week watch yeah
but now we can at least on ironically
use Papa ah Papa nice cast Bubba don't
do that one all right you're right and
then when he goes on the show and goes
oh Brent needs a Handler and my friends
and family call me like rosencina I
called him I text him he was I tried
calling him text him he didn't pick up I
was like hey are you shooting me dude
Handler and then he wrote me this long
thing like you're right should have said
that you know but and he gave me his
reason I went I know but you don't need
he was right he shouldn't said that
you're not helping my cause dude I'm
already fighting a good fight here what
good fight what good fight are you I'm
sorry I understand that people
recovering approaching against the dying
of
yeah [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] she's what
are you talking about
the oncoming storm of you not being able
to control your bowels because your
brain got punched in a [ __ ] pudding
Brandon let's relax man yo I'm talking
about I'm fighting a good fight here I'm
like basically like the finished
resistance during the Nazi times bro
yeah I'm sure I'm sure [ __ ] selling
mid whiskey and dress and dressing like
a dressing like a [ __ ] Zoomer is
really fighting the good fight what are
you fighting a good fight with huh Jesus
Christ your food trucks is that what
you're doing
you're not helping me he said you're
right won't do it again unless God would
never do that to you ever do so it
sounds like Joe kind of apologized to
Brennan for it I don't believe it but
even though who the hell knows what
really happened because Brendan never
really tells the truth he always kind of
changes up the story a little bit but
it's funny that all his friends and
family were telling them right away like
dude Joe just said you needed a Handler
like it's this big news and then Brendan
could even get Joe to answer the call it
sounds like yeah text him that sucks but
I think Joe is probably just too busy
playing grab ass with Mark Zuckerberg
I'm not the one playing grabass was Mark
Zuckerberg letting him ran out thick Boy
Studio and now I'm talking like man for
some reason yeah it's his new gimmick
it's so annoying
Brennan stop
you don't need a Handler all right what
you need is to stop doing comedy and
then everything's fine everything else
will fix itself Baba